Mẹ hai thành chiến tạo hôm nghỉ tương lạc lực lượng của Phòng ASEAN là thứ 2, Mẹ hai.
ASEAN đẹp mở hai hai.
Thế nhà lãnh đạo quân sự của bựng đạc thống nhất thành lập lực lượng đạc nghiệm chung.
Để đối phó với các mùi đe dây suả nền phí trình thống.
Lực lượng này được sáng như bụx sự lĩ như phản đề nổi lên như tổ phạm mạng.
Sa lần chịch tuyến, cũng như điều phối tổng đồng cứu chợi tham hoạch trong ASEAN.
Tương lạc lượng của Phòng ASEAN, đại từ một đi châm chà phà nhấn mạnh.
Lực lượng đàn nghiệm là bất đi quan chào.
ASEAN có thể phối hợp hành động ở cấp cá nhấn, thì sả khủng hả.
Tất nhiên, phản nếng nấu lực tăng cường hợp tác cuo Phòng,
và sây dựng lòng tên dựa các nước hành viên,
phù ở bình huyn tác khu bật qua bên tự sau và chú lập.
Hôm nghỉ cũng khẳng đề, thế được buộc đầy các sáng kiện như bộ của tắc ở dưới dưới dưới dưới biển.
Hương giấm tựa con dưới dưới dưới không và chí biển.
Nhanh giúp chí ở định và đi cú bật.
Năm anh nhìn không chá mi sao, quên chú tích ASEAN mở tựa truyền tựa mà là gia sáng tili tên.